joseph are you coming for easter i don't
know mom i'm really busy i just tested
for this pilot you're going to be a
pilot a network pilot for like a tv show
ah you're playing a pilot on the tv show
no a lawyer you could have been a lawyer
if you only applied yourself
a little father and son road trip it's
gonna be fun easter sunday is like the
filipino super bowl there he
welcome home is
see you tonight okay i just got here you
got to follow your dream and become a
beer spokesman that was my dream let's
get the party started baby
and i got to follow mom's dream and
become a nurse
joe vanessa yeah joe valencia you still
driving that same raggedy ass car what
what happened you just gave up huh and
it's your dad you know me and him used
to be real intimate back in the day oh
really yeah i could have been your mama
but clearly i'm not yeah i've literally
never seen this many filipinos in the
same place before
we're sending gifts to our family in the
philippines i'm sending this brand new
hairdryer if it makes your hair look
like that i wouldn't send it how dare
you how dare you we should put them both
in the box and ship it
my mom is at war with my tita theresa
and they don't even know why did you
really have to wear the same dress as my
mom oh i can't help it if i wear it
better this is war oops
family is a mess we're counting on you
to fix it bye
ladies and gentlemen
for all we got so let's get the party
started baby i got a feeling
moments like these are few and far
between let's enjoy it
buckle up
filipino families fight a lot make sure
you're not late for dinner but we love a
lot too
your cousin eugene owes me a lot of
money
can you lend it to me no
does he have a death wish deluxe is
legit crazy i once saw him shoot
somebody in a dick what right in the
actual hole in the hole
where is my money here are my atm cards
my pin number is 12 17. oh also is mine
oh my god my my pills yeah why do you
all have the same pin number it's manny
pacquiao's
oh right the guy who couldn't beat
mayweather
that's a can we go get coffee you can go
ahead and email me pretty much the same
just take the aol off that [ __ ] nessa
at
daleycity.com got it
[Music]
you